that conscious effort to change a
behavior
makes us uncomfortable even though it
may be good for us it makes us
uncomfortable for a day seven days 20
days 30 days
that period of time
is what we call as the switch cost okay
and if people understand that you've got
to do something for about 66 days not 20
days not 40 but the latest research says
that
to
to make the switch cost stick
commit to at least 66 days
and your brain will then take what you
have to consciously think about what you
constantly have to put effort towards
doing it'll make it automatic so you
don't have to think about it i love that
and so the first part is whatever goal
you want to achieve first ask yourself
am i prepared
to pay the switch cost
to be
uncomfortable long enough to make my new
thoughts my new emotions and my new
behaviors
the default the new default yes because
once it's like the browser that's set on
your computer it's the automatic it's
automatic yes and if you think about our
lives most of what we do is automatic we
don't deviate very much from when we
wake up when we go to sleep what we
watch what we eat where we exercise who
we hang out what clothes do we wear
we're pretty much creatures of habit yes
the key is
most of the habits that people have like
i'm referring to habits as emotions
thoughts and behaviors right are geared
towards helping you achieve exactly what
you are achieving right now and
for those of you that don't think that
you are committed you are to those
results yes to those who don't think you
are disciplined yes you are to those
thoughts and feelings and behaviors
right the key is to become committed
more committed
to your new vision whether it's your
body your relationship your health your
business
and then pay the switch cost long enough
to make that
the new you
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
john ashraf and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two master your mindset
until you learn how to master your
mindset
by recognizing what's holding you back
the real reasons that you're not taking
the actions that you need to take
and learn how to reframe them in the
right part of your brain so you can
override the messaging signal from the
amygdala the fear center the emotional
center of the brain to the
part of the brain that's responsible for
taking action
you're never going to achieve your goals
so whether you have doubts or fears or
anxieties fear of success fear failure
if you're losing your job if you're
losing your home if you're losing your
money
you have to understand that just like
a car
has a light that pops up on the
dashboard when something's wrong in the
engine
you have an emotion that is your signal
to let you know whether you're feeling
good or not whether you're comfortable
or not whether you have certainty or not
whether you have confidence or not
and if you're lacking the confidence and
the certainty
it's going to cause doubt if you're
going to have doubt it may cause anxiety
and as soon as that sets into the brain
in a nanosecond
your ability to take action
is like having one foot on the gas and
one foot on the brake
there's gonna be a lot of movement going
on the tires but you're really not gonna
get anywhere
so the first thing i want you to do
is write down what's really holding you
back
why aren't you really get clear get deep
why aren't you really taking action
towards any of your goals health goals
financial goals business goals whatever
goals you have
write that down
and ask yourself
is this real
is this imagined is it a probability or
is it a possibility what you'll find
for the most part is the negative
consequence
is a possibility and as soon as you buy
into that possibility
you're going to do everything possible
to run away to fight freeze or fight
that feeling
but when you learn how to switch your
brain from recognizing what's holding
you back
to reframing the possibility to
do for the probability to just a normal
possibility
you start to activate
different parts of your brain that
starts showing you the solutions
to how to overcome the fear how to
overcome the risk how to overcome the
possible negative consequence and then
what happens is the amygdala the part of
your brain that's responsible to protect
you and to keep you safe
the firing threshold of that signal gets
lowered
the message to the motor cortex doesn't
get sent so you start to take action
and third what is happening
is that your left prefrontal cortex the
ceo the genius part of your brain
starts to think about ways that you can
actually take action and do it faster
and easier and better it starts to
change what you see start to change your
vibration and now you start to have
a lot more control
over not just having goals and having
strategies and plans but getting
yourself to take action rule number
three make a commitment if we said
in a year we all want to jog a marathon
together and let's say you're in awful
shape right now but we started with a
five minute walk today
and then five minute walk tomorrow five
minute walk the next day that maybe ten
minutes then maybe fifteen maybe a light
jog thirty days from now
is it possible that with the commitment
that we're gonna do a marathon in a year
and the beginning commitment to doing a
little bit today a little bit more each
day including getting massaged and
eating well and resting and getting a
right program for how much we should
train
is it possible that almost every one of
us a year from now could slowly jog a
marathon
the answer is yes that means that the
issue is not that you can't run a
marathon that means that a you haven't
made a commitment to run a marathon and
then you haven't put together the
process
in order to do it safely and effectively
which means that i don't care what your
current situation is right now there is
a way out you have to start with your
commitment
and then get started rule number four
create a vision board whenever i want to
create anything whether it's my physical
body a home a car a trip
there's a big part of our brain called
the occipital lobe back of our brain
even when light comes in through our
eyes right cells in the back of our
brain activate and an image pops up in
our brain
and that image that pops up into our
brain is connected to the motivational
center and the thinking center part of
our brain
so if a negative image pops up we reduce
our motivation and we don't take action
and then we reinforce that pattern but
let's say i have a an image of something
that i really want something that
inspires me
that as soon as i pop up that image in
my brain i actually release dopamine
okay uh the reward neurochemical in my
brain that actually creates motivation
that's actually tied to what i call as
the einstein part of the part of the
brain that can actually help you figure
out how to achieve that thing
and so i create
images of what is it that i want to
create for health wealth relations
career business charity fun and
experiences so that i can activate the
reward circuits in my brain the
motivational circuits in my brain the
thinking centers of my brain to help me
figure out how to achieve it but the
other purpose of a vision board is to
give your brain the instruction of this
is the stuff that's important to me that
i want to create do be have or give
right so you know we all have you know
50 000 thoughts a day we all have so
much on the social media whether it's
facebook or instagram or youtube or
clubhouse or whatever all the different
you know stations and channels are the
people that want to get gather our
attention well why don't we become
better at focusing our attention on what
we want to trade our life for
right because when somebody is pulling
us to look at their stuff
like
we're
we're part of their goals and dreams and
and their vision versus me being focused
on what is it that i want to trade my
life for and instructing my brain help
me find ways to trade my life for these
things
and that's how to use your brain
properly
um versus your brain using you
because it may not have you know been
conditioned properly with the right
beliefs and focus and awareness and
habits
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five be consistent one of
the things that i
that i really uh learned many many years
ago
was something
around habits
and
the habit is more important than the
intensity
yeah the
consistency if you can get into
doing something
productive constructive every day every
day
you will continue to do something pro
your goals pro your health pro whatever
it is every day
and some days
i have a trainer that comes to my home
as well
and some days i'm exhausted i'm
just exhausted but i still go through
the motions
even when i'm exhausted yeah because the
habit's more important to me than the
intensity so i some days i feel like i
don't want to work out right i still do
something i don't care if i lay on the
ground and my trainer moves my legs or
my arms i just move my neck left and
right i've still done
right something
to create movement and to enforce or
reinforce a positive habit that is part
of the nucleus of success rule number
six recognize your emotions and there
are seven core emotions that people have
you know happiness sadness fear disgust
shame guilt
those are just emotions and it's either
something that's happening
on the inside that's causing that
emotion something that you know we
associate with what we're doing or
something from the outside that's
instigating that emotion and so the
first part of any change is to recognize
the emotion that i'm feeling
and not laying judgment on it but
accepting it as just energy in motion
it's either pleasant or unpleasant
something we want to move towards or
move away from
so once we recognize it the question
then becomes is it real is it true
that i'm feeling this as a result of the
meaning that i'm giving it
and in most cases it's not true it's
something that we have become
conditioned to believe is true because
of the references or because of our own
experiences that we have around that
issue
and the way our brain works is anytime
that we feel uncertain
about something that may cause us harm
or pain a part of our brain called the
reptilian brain actually activates in a
billionth of a second
a fierce circuit which caused us to
either flee which means run away freeze
which means we do nothing or fight it
which means we're in most in most cases
fighting air
and so if we can reframe something the
meaning of it long enough to let the
emotion pass
that causes the third r to be activated
that's the release of an unpleasant
emotion rule number seven don't choose a
life of regret when someone is really
having a hard life hard time they're in
the situation that
they don't want to like i don't want to
practice my innocence i don't want to
visualize
what suggestion you have for them you
know when they have the dark knight of
the soul
well
listen if you don't feel like doing
something
once in a while then you're human
but
like let me know if this resonates with
you and whoever's listening let me know
if it resonates with you
do you agree with this statement
in life you're going to either pay the
price of discipline
or you're going to pay the price of
regret
discipline weighs ounces regret weighs
tons
that's jim rohn by the way and so
when you're sitting there and saying i
don't feel like it
my question for you is what do you not
feel like it more doing this little
thing
or living a life of regret
wow that's huge
right so let's create
a juxtaposition against what i don't
feel like doing
and let's
use contrasting to say are you okay
with this being your character are you
okay with this being your life forever
are you okay with developing a lazy
habit and lazy disciplines are you okay
for the next one year three years five
years 10 years 20 years 30 40 years
having that as your modus apparanda and
your identity
if you're okay with that don't feel like
it don't do it but then don't complain
and don't want any more
but if you're not okay
with the short-term and long-term
consequences of that
decision then here's what i want you to
say
i know i don't feel like it but
i will do just a little bit rule number
eight upgrade your software what if
you said okay i want to make let's just
say a hundred thousand dollars a year or
a million it doesn't make a difference
and i asked you
what do you need to believe about
yourself
to achieve this so i need to believe i'm
smart enough good write down i am smart
enough what else do you need to believe
i need to believe that i am worthy i
need to believe that i deserve this i
need to believe that it's possible i
need to believe you write down five or
six or seven beliefs they're just words
on a sheet of paper
now let me stop for just a moment i'm
going to tell a story and come back to
this i want you to imagine
that somebody tapped you
on the shoulder sometime today and say
hey
um i work with steven spielberg and tom
hanks in hollywood and we have this new
script okay that if you get really good
at this script where you could read it
in front of a camera without the script
we'll pay you 10 million bucks
now i want you to imagine you've never
seen the script you don't know how to
act but they said to you we're going to
give you an acting coach we're going to
give you everything you need to memorize
the script we're giving you everything
you need to act it perfectly what would
you do
to take that script that's on a piece of
paper that you've never seen before what
would you do to take that script
to make it yours for you to own it and
the answer is you probably read it like
what once
would you read it maybe 100 times 200
times 500 times do you think you might
role play with somebody while you're
holding the script in your hand do you
think you might research the role do you
think you might take a camera and
practice it and you think that if you
practice it one time 50 times 100 times
500 times you can finally put the script
down and you can get in front of the
camera and go boom here is the script do
you think you could do that well guess
what a script that's on a piece of paper
that you don't believe with practice you
start to believe so what happens if you
take a belief
system and you start to imprint it into
your subconscious mind initially through
conscious repetition but there are ways
to access the subconscious mind that we
know today that are faster and easier
than just doing it consciously and so
you take a vision of you achieving your
goals and dreams you take the beliefs
you need you learn how to manage your
emotions a little bit better and then
you develop the habits which again are
nothing more than neural patterns in the
brain that have been reinforced when you
learn how to deactivate the destructive
ones and activate constructive ones
through space repetition and
reinforcement now you are resetting your
default way of being
so a belief is nothing more than a
reinforced pattern that if you learn how
to deactivate it and create a new one
it's like a software upgrade for your
brain rule number nine prime your brain
daily one of the things
that um i would like everyone to
consider
is um every day
okay how can you direct your brain
okay where you want the attention to go
right so
um there's a saying in neuroscience that
um energy flows to where attention goes
energy flows to where attention goes so
if you think of negative things and you
predict that you know you're going to be
embarrassed to shame ridicule judge
you're going to fail then the energy and
attention goes there and your brain then
predicts that that's going to be the
reality
so we're predicting in advance what we
think might happen but by the same time
if you predict you're going to be
successful healthy happy financially
secure you're going to be enjoying life
then the energy goes there so i do
something every day called
cognitive priming or i prime my brain
and every day i take out my goals
my vision my goals my why
and what i want to achieve
and i
have a discussion with my brain
on being very very clear on help me
achieve these things
help these things become a reality show
me the tools the resources the people
that i need in order to make this my
reality
so i'm putting my brain to work instead
of allowing it to do what it naturally
wants to do which is repeatable patterns
so i am developing the new patterns like
a software engineer you know create
software
i am just programming my own brain every
day on what to focus on
do that every day focus on what you want
instead of what you don't want watch the
magic start to happen and rule number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is shield your beliefs when
somebody is challenging your thoughts
somebody's challenging your identity
somebody's challenging your ideas
and you're allowing what they say to
override what you know
in most cases it's because you're
lacking self-esteem yourself you're
lacking confidence with the product or
the service of the idea and so it really
is never about what they're saying
it's about your interpretation and your
automatic response to what they're
saying
so the meaning that we give anything
determines how we feel about it so the
question is well how do i change the
meaning of what somebody says to me how
do i put a shield around myself
when somebody says something negative to
me so that it doesn't affect me and one
of the things again to do is instead of
be in a state of reacting
be in a state of observation be in a
state of awareness
of why is it when joe or mary or harry
or sally said x that i feel
a certain way
and it's because of the meaning that we
have given things in our own minds
and so the key is not to try and get
people to say
fewer of those things the key is for us
to be able to accept any kind of
external stimuli
and do with it what we choose
and is there a way that you can learn
how to give anything that happens a
positive meaning that's number one
number two
when most people have
a negative comment it's because of their
experience their story their
believability around that idea that is
causing their reaction so you can choose
to accept it or you can choose to reject
it in either case if you're the one
making the choice then you're never
going to be a victim of somebody else's
stimuli
and it reminds me of a wonderful a
wonderful little story about buddha he
was walking into a village and about an
hour outside this village this person
came up to him
and and kept berating him how silly he
was how stupid he was how he wasn't
there to serve people he was there only
for self gain and buddha wasn't
responding to this individual he just
kept sending him love and prayers and
good wishes and finally just before they
got into town this guy said well i'm i'm
i'm antagonizing you i'm telling you all
these negative things how come you're
not responding to me and buddha said
something brilliant he said listen if
somebody offers you a gift and you
choose not to accept the gift to whom
does the gift belong and so obviously if
somebody's giving you feedback that
isn't going to serve you
just don't accept the feedback
just don't accept it as part of your
truth or reality stay true to your own
knowing stay true to your own confidence
and certainty and that way you'll be in
control of your own destiny versus what
people say or don't say
let's say you ask yourself a question
and you say to yourself
i don't know
say i don't know have you ever done that
am i the only one that sometimes want to
ask a question i go i don't know
then i ask myself i understand
but if i did know what could it be
so i want to go layer by layer by layer
to ask better questions the better
questions i ask
the more my brain will look to solve the
answer won't it right so i ask really
good questions of my brain and if i ask
myself why am i procrastinating i don't
know
say well if i did know
what would it be i don't know
well
could i go on to google and find out why
i procrastinate yes am i willing to sure
when right now
right if i go down another path if i
don't know
is it possible that somebody else knows
the answer to this is there a book that
the answer is in is there a youtube
video is there an instagram post is
there something on pinterest yeah is
there something
somewhere
online that i can find an answer to my
question if i keep saying i don't know
so the answer is of course the answer's
there it's
the middle of 2021 of course the answers
are here the answer here for how to lose
weight and keep it off the answer here
on how to double your income in the next
12 months the answers are here for how
to leave a job that you hate and get a
new one that you love the answers here
for how to start a business the answers
here
for how to put a rocket ship on mars the
answer is here for how to be
spiritually connected the answers the
answers are here so is it possible
that
maybe we haven't learned to be great
question askers
and if it's possible that this
biocomputer
always finds the answer
based on the questions that we're asking
so if you ask yourself you know why
can't i ever achieve this
your brain's going to go let me show you
why you know why is this so hard well
i'll show you why you know how come i
can't figure it out those are
questions
ask questions whereby the answer means
you're moving forward did you hear that
ask questions whereby the answer you
give yourself moves you forward so
you're never stuck finding the answer to
the problem you find the answer to the
solution did you hear that don't find
the answer to the problem or the
obstacle find the answer to the solution
what has to happen in order for me to
take action whose help do i need to take
action what do i need to learn what do i
need to start what should i stop there
are a variety of different ways to find
ways to remove the darkness we can read
we can go to youtube and watch videos we
can be on social media we can join
groups we can be part of masterminds we
can hire a coach we can go and work for
somebody you know who knows how to do
what you want to learn how to do and so
the first part though
is to become resourceful in the absence
of resources so i'll give you an example
mr brown says i'll be your your mentor
your guru and i said awesome and the
next thing he said to me says well i
need you to move from montreal to
toronto i said
what i don't know anybody in toronto i
said i don't have any money to get an
apartment i don't have a car i don't
have you know i don't have a job he says
well you don't need money a car an
apartment or a job first you need to
make the decision then you figure out
how to get all the rest yeah i said i
know but you don't understand
i left high school in grade 11. i have
60 in the bank he says that's okay he
says make the decision then you figure
out how so i said
well maybe i could move in with my
brother my best yeah i can move in with
me short term sleep on the sofa because
it's only a one bedroom apartment that i
live in and uh so i ended up moving to
toronto
and then right after that um
at the same same
sentence the same lunch that i had with
him he said and i need you to enroll in
the real estate school um that costs 500
and it starts on april the 20th and this
was in 1980 just to give you an example
oh i like
that's it myself said
you want me to go back to school i left
school at grade 11. i failed english i
failed math i'm terrible school and i
need 500 i only have 60 dollars in the
bank account
i understand but first you make the
decision um and then you figure out how
i said mr brown i don't have any money
like i can't make the decision you know
to go into school he says oh yes you can
he says many people
think that you have to have the tools
the knowledge the skills the resources
before you make the decision and he said
you know john f kennedy made a decision
to put a man safely on the moon and
return them back to earth before we even
had the technology to be able to do that
he says
average people look at their current
circumstances and their past and they
allow that to dictate what they do or
don't do he says highly successful
people create a vision for what they
want and then they use their powerful
brain to figure out how they can because
they must
so i said
fine i'll find the money well my brother
then said well i can lend you 100 bucks
my mother lent me some money my sister
led me some money three weeks later i
moved to toronto took the real estate
course five weeks later i passed the
real estate test because i studied every
day and he showed me how to and so in
five weeks i moved to another state i
found the money for a course i didn't
have money for i passed the test even
though i thought i wasn't very smart i
became a licensed real estate agent
all because
i made a commitment to doing it even
though i didn't know how even though i
didn't have the resources the financial
or non-financial resources
so one of the greatest lessons he shared
with me
is vision comes first
goals come second
strategies of how you're going to
achieve them come third if you take a
look at um you know um dr j and you take
a look at vince carty take a look at
dwayne wade you take a look at any of
the players today lebron
they studied the patterns
of other great players and that's what
is really fun is i mean that's the fun
i'm having now is i know
uh that if i gave a hundred people
the blueprint of what to do
one might do it
but if i trained a hundred people's
brains to focus on what i want them to
focus on i trained them how to manage
their emotions
and i gave them a blueprint of what to
do i get 60 to take action and follow
through
and you may ask how do i know this
because i know when i used to
sell our coaching programs for 5 ten
twenty thirty fifty a hundred thousand
dollars when we didn't do the mindset
training and the emotional management
training
the success of our clients was maybe
five or six percent
and when we did include the mindset
the emotional management and the skill
sets
62 percent of our clients started to
achieve phenomenal success oh why that
makes you cry
why that makes your credit the deeper
you can get this
um and deeper you can not be afraid to
go there
and say yes i matter and i and i can
make a difference in my life and my
friends or kids or husband or wife and
family and community and mankind
that that that is what inspires you yes
right it's spirit within you is
expressing itself that way versus doing
things that expire you when you minimize
who you are
you're expiring your spirit wow
versus doing things that that inspired
that allow spirit to express itself more
fully spirit is always for fuller
expression and expansion of itself
right but we get these disempowering
expiring beliefs and habits and
perspective and perceptions from
ignorant people that we grew up around
not because they were bad people they
just didn't know they didn't know any
better they didn't know any better and
now we know better
and so if we know better let's do better
better feel better and be better and
give better and
and that's what it's all about the law
of bigger fears
states this
do you agree that there is um a way to
frame things that are more painful
if you
give things certain meaning so let me
explain the law of bigger fears
let's say you're procrastinating
on
a project on
anything doesn't make a difference can
you put your uh something that you're
procrastinating in the chat right now so
put whatever it is that you're
procrastinating okay
right now if you can alright
put something in the chat of what you're
procrastinating right now let me share
with you the law of bigger fears so we
talked about the law of little actions
we talked about the law of secondary
gains but let's take a look at anything
that you are procrastinating right now i
want you to write out okay and you don't
have to do it uh right now but if you
ask yourself uh what
am i
gaining ben how am i gaining by
procrastinating so i feel safe i feel
secure
i don't have to expend energy etc also
next to that i want you to write down
what is the cost of procrastinating
what's the cost of procrastinating like
this
on your self-worth and self-esteem
on your income on your relationship on
your self-image of how you see yourself
on your self trust so
if and when i procrastinating the cost
to me
is more than just the completion of the
goal but the cost to me
is loss of self respect the cost to me
as i reinforce a pattern of
procrastination the cost to me
is i repeat patterns that i reinforce
the cost to me
what is the cost to you of
procrastinating and here's what we can
do
if you make the cost to you
bigger
than the reward you're getting for not
doing it
let me repeat that
if you make the cost of not doing it the
bigger fear the bigger cost
greater
than the cost or i'm sorry
that the reward you're getting
then now we have what's called is a
contrast frame
not doing this
gives me you know this which we know we
get but not doing this also costs me
this and reinforces this so now you say
not doing it i get these rewards but
here is what the cost is of staying in
my job michelle here's what the real
cost is on my income my self-worth my
self-esteem my children my spouse my
significant other and if you believe and
agree with me
that whatever behaviors we reinforce we
become
whatever behaviors we reinforce we
become why because of something called
automaticity in the brain once we
reinforce a pattern the pattern then
moves into a subconscious automated
sequence so there's no thought involved
in repeating the pattern because it's
easy and it doesn't require any very
little energy so when we're talking
about the law of bigger fears the law of
bigger costs
now we can use a contrast frame and our
brain is great at avoiding the bigger
pain
did you hear what i just said
your brain my brain is great at avoiding
the bigger of the two pains
and
since we do more to avoid pain than we
do to gain pleasure
if we're procrastinating because we're
gaining some kind of safety and pleasure
our brain will move away from the
greater of the two and the greater the
two is moving away from the bigger cost
let's say
you have
a shortage of money right now
let's say you're not uh earning as much
as you'd like and there's too much month
left at the end of the money too much
month left at the end of money creates
stress
uh decisions around money can create
stress what to buy what not to buy is it
too expensive is it you know not
expensive enough for my taste whatever
the
the the the stress is um i want you to
understand stress a little bit
differently from the from the brain
perspective this is the um
part of the brain the the brain stem
that is attached to the first part of
being called the reptilian brain which
is connected very very quickly to the
amygdala the stress response center in
the brain
when we have stress in our life whether
it's money stress emotional stress
relationship stress business stress
career stress whatever stress we have
the signal that is sent through
the electrical system in the brain and
the chemical system in the brain when
stress is activated
there's a part of the brain called the
vagus nerve and the sympathetic nervous
system which is part of your autonomic
nervous system but the sympathetic
nervous system specifically
is the system that activates a stress
response system activates one of four
things
fear
okay
um and when and we'll talk about fear in
just a moment but when we're in a state
of stress the fight or flight response
kicks in the sympathetic nervous system
so when we're in a fight
mindset
we are we are using a lot of epinephrine
adrenaline cortisol and there's this
current of anxiety
now that's not that bad if it's a little
bit but when it's too much it actually
deactivates the thinking part of your
brain that can actually solve the reason
you're stressed so when we are in this
fight or flight which is runaway
modality
or the freeze or faint modal there are
people who freeze when they're under too
much stress there are people who faint
under too much stress there are people
um who who run away and there's people
who just try to fight it so
when we are looking at the brain
and we're looking at stress okay this is
what a heidi's talking about here she
says stress is our own gps system saying
that something
is out of alignment
and the energy movement from the common
respond part of the brain is gone to the
stress and react part of the brain and
so
one of the the tools to calm the brain
down to go from reactive stress
to relax and respond
is inner size number one that we teach
and that you're all going to be able to
learn in my new book
called inner size but inner size number
one is called take six calm the circuits
so whenever you're feeling stressed
whenever there's a problem whenever
you're feeling overwhelmed whenever
you're feeling confused whenever you're
feeling like it's too much stop
as opposed to trying to fight your way
through it stop calm down
close your eyes
take six deep breaths like this
in through your nose gently in a rhythm
of about
six breaths
per minute every 10 seconds
and when
you do a breathing exercise take six
calm the circuits that's inner size
number one you actually deactivate the
stress response center in the brain and
you activate the calm
and respond part of the brain i thought
i was afraid of public speaking right i
thought that was oh i would just say i'm
a bad public speaker that was my story
well you're absolutely right what you
said
that's what it was i was afraid of
judgment i was afraid of rejection and
that was what was holding me back and
these are subconscious patterns right so
the feeling okay
is this
uncomfortable which is very
uncomfortable uh it's it's stressful
it's it creates anxiety
and so it's not the public speaking
so the question is where did you learn
to have this idea that
speaking in public causes you to be
embarrassed ashamed ridiculed or judged
and here's what a lot of people will say
if you ask them like where did that come
from they'll say well you know when i
was a kid in class
and you know the teacher asked the
question and i answered and the answer
was wrong you know the other kids made
fun of me or the teacher said no that's
not the right answer and and and you
know they were embarrassed and the other
kids ridiculed them and so like who the
hell wants that
so if our brain is focusing on
wiring whatever keeps us safe and
whatever keeps pain away
we avoid pain or we'll do anything to
avoid pain
way before we do anything to gain
pleasure
and so survival first avoidance of pain
second before we gain pleasure so if
there's any real or imagined danger
where we're gonna be emotionally hurt
mentally hurt physically hurt
financially hurt
our brain gives us this signal be aware
this may be one of those times
it says be aware this may be one of
those times and so
the the cycle the neural circuit the
cycle shouldn't stop there
but when you people haven't been trained
on here are my six core emotions here
are my feelings that those emotions
cause and here's what to do when this
emotion is triggered do this
when this emotion is triggered do that
and what you want to do is learn
when the motion of fear is triggered the
neurochemistry is adrenaline cortisol
epinephrine norepinephrine that's like
this high anxiety rocket fuel within us
now in most people
it caused them to just stop put on the
brake uh-huh but how is it that a
firefighter
okay
could could see a building blowing up in
front of them a building crashing down a
raging fire
and yet she musters up the courage to
use that fuel from fear and go in
it's because she's been trained yep
that's because she's been trained
there's einstein which represents our
left prefrontal cort cortex the
the smart genius part of our brain that
has imagination that can come up with
all the ideas of what about this what
about this i can have this i can have
this but what most people don't
understand is we also have right a
frankenstein part of our brain the inner
critic you know it says but you're not
good enough you're not smart enough what
if you fail what if you're embarrassed
what if you're ashamed so we have this
you know that's why i have them there's
einstein and there's frankenstein just
to remind me and to remind my students
that both exist within us
and our goal is to understand that you
know the way our brain works is there's
always a protective side of our brain so
frankenstein's always going what if you
fail what if you succeed and fail what
if you disappoint yourself and
einstein's going don't worry about it
imagine the future and so there's this
constant battle in our brains you know
going on in our goal and meditation is
one of the best ways to recognize that
both exist
and both are right your frankenstein
part of your brain is there to protect
you your einstein brain is ready to help
you achieve your goals and dreams and
the key is to remember you're not your
brain you're not the einstein part
you're not the frankenstein part there's
another side of you that is much greater
than all of it mark waldman in his um
little training over here says
seven days of gratitude exercise the
more you focus on your thoughts the more
your brain becomes habituated to it the
brain the brain tends to pay more
attention to negative thoughts this is
based on the instinctual parts of the
brain we can train ourselves to focus on
the positives as well
at the end of the day he says
write down three things you feel
grateful for and three things you did
well
this can change your brain you only have
to for seven days and you will see your
self-esteem grow for three months so
when we are giving you you know uh
gratitude things to do anything we're
teaching you to do it's all based in
neuroscience research
and so the more you're grateful the more
you have to be grateful for the more you
train your brain to be grateful the more
it looks and becomes habituated to look
for other things to be grateful for i
tend to be a goal seeking guy right
and i used to not celebrate the small
stuff and i just it's just like you know
bigger goal bigger goal bigger goal more
bigger bigger and somebody says to me
like are you gonna like slow down just
to enjoy some of the stuff that you
actually have done for yourself and for
people in your family and i was like
well uh
let me create an accomplished board
oh good so good
so accomplished
you passed that test on your own 40
years ago
celebrate that you helped this person
who was challenged celebrate that you
know you did this for him or for her or
for yourself celebrate that stuff to
remind yourself
because i i'm tough on myself like i'm
let's come on let's go it's a goal let's
go
um and sometimes i forget the stuff that
i have done the stuff that i do do
that
i need to remember so i created an
accomplishments board and a list so i
can just go to it when i feel like holy
am i am i smart enough to achieve
that next thing am i good enough what a
lot of people don't know ed is so good
when i was a kid i used to feel like i
wasn't smart enough
and when i was a kid it held me back
and today i still feel like i'm not
smart enough and that fuels me to get
smarter so i use it
like i said big goals like oh god i
don't have the skills i don't have the
knowledge but i can figure it out i've
got contacts i've got friends there's
books there's google there's there's
youtube there's holy mackerel i don't
need to have all the specialized
knowledge anymore not having a sales
process
not having a sales process what does
that mean
so let me share with you
just a sales process so you need to
think
in systems
right if this and this and this and this
happens then x is predictable
so let's say you are going to um
do a instagram live
facebook live youtube live linkedin live
event
you have to think past the event
then what
like if somebody comes to your event if
somebody reads your blog if somebody um
reads your twitter feed if somebody
watches your tick tock
like then what
like
what is the process by which you share
your
product service or knowledge information
tidbits around the things that you want
to share
then what like what do you want them to
do next
now before you ask people to do
something like give you their email oh i
want your email before you ask them to
you know sign up for this free event or
this paid event
you have to give them value
right give them value
give them something tangible
and don't be afraid to give give give
give when i wrote my book intersize all
of my books
everything that i write in my books
is the stuff in my head that i'm working
with clients who pay me five thousand
dollars an hour they just want to go
deeper on the work for me to help them
implement it
but i wanna give give give give value
value value
value and then i can say hey if you want
to go deeper
get my books you want to go deeper
get my programs you want to go deeper
get into my coaching program you want to
go deeper hire me as a consultant but
first
give the knowledge so here's the
question that you want to ask yourself
what
problem does your product or service
solve
what fear does it eliminate
what
uh pain does it eliminate uh what gain
do people have because of product
whenever i am looking to give people
content i'm always looking at
understanding
what are the pains fears frustrations
irritations wants needs and aspirations
let me repeat what are
the pains fears frustrations irritations
wants needs and aspirations of
the person who wants to buy
whatever it is you know that i have to
offer doesn't mean there's somebody sold
all this stuff by the way here's my
gratitude coin right
gratitude so so you know whether it's
glasses spray a pen a magnifying glass a
gratitude coin uh the camera that i'm
looking into the computer the stand
somebody had to sell that and every
single product or service
either eliminates a pain fear for space
irritation or helps people with a want
need or aspiration right
so how do you give somebody
content and information and value in
advance
and i'll sit on my board or on my
keyboard and i will ask what is it that
people want and need that i could help
them with
and then i create whether it's blogs
articles
videos process maps and i give them away
lack of knowledge and skills
so lack of knowledge and skills so
when we don't have let's say we have a
goal
any goal it doesn't make a difference
whether it's a relationship goal money
charity whatever it is whenever we lack
the knowledge or the skills
there's a part of us that has self-doubt
self-doubt is what triggers
fear
because they're worried we don't know
enough right so if we don't know enough
if we don't have the knowledge or the
skill or we think we have to have this
certain knowledge or skill
that we don't have or that you know that
we think we need it's going to trigger
self-doubt self-doubt triggers fear fear
deactivates motivational centers in the
brain and deactivates the thinking part
of the brain in our imagination
it's circuits it's all it is is circuits
turning on or off yes
and so in the absence of knowledge and
skill of what to do about it
we default to not taking action because
we're protecting ourselves yep
right and so all of these little
mechanisms you know these four uh key
ones
um
cause us to trigger the uh
procrastination circuit in the brain
they do not take action circuit in the
brain yes
right and you know guys or girls when
they're dating you know if they feel
uncertain then they just stay there well
maybe he'll come and talk to me well
maybe she'll come and talk to me and and
it just goes round and round and round
and round it's like a muscle your brain
has neuro muscles
okay right so if you think about you
know we have if we want to build our
bicep muscle or our chest or our
shoulders or our legs we go to the gym
we do exercises or we go and hike or run
or bike or walk or or do whatever it is
well what do you do to strengthen your
confidence muscle
what do you do to strengthen your
self-esteem muscle what do you do to
strengthen your tenacity or resolve
muscle what do you do
to to strengthen any of your core
neural muscles like awareness how do you
strengthen your awareness how do you
strengthen your ability to focus and
stay laser
disciplined on an achievement of a goal
these are all neural muscles that you
can strengthen but nobody up until now
has come up with here are the inner
sizes for your neural muscles instead of
the exercises for your physical muscles
until neurogym and inner size the first
inner size that you teach anyway it's
kind of like learning the alphabet first
so take six com the circus there's three
foundational inner sides we teach in the
book there's many more but the first one
is just to deactivate the stress
reactive center in the brain and you do
that through six deep breaths in 10
second increments so you take a deep
breath in through your nose
and then as you blow out pretend you're
blowing out through a straw so all of
your energy is towards that focus right
so three two one
you do that six times and we can see in
brain scan images that the stress
response center lowers and in many cases
deactivates which throws blood back to
the left prefrontal cortex your state of
awareness increases and then you can
move to inner size number two which is
called iaia
which is now in a calm relaxed state
now
the first a stands for awareness of my
thoughts emotions feelings sensations
and what have been my behaviors for
let's say the last five minutes or hour
awareness without shame blame guilt
justification or judgment pure awareness
calm state then what is my intention
well my intention is to be happy i've
been feeling sad my intentions to be
happy my intention is to be focused not
scattered great let me let me write give
myself one or two intentions then the
next a stands for what's one action to
move me towards that so if your
intention is to be happy why not look up
and smile
just look up and smile because when you
look up and smile you release the
neurochemistry of happiness and you
cannot look up and be angry sad mad
discipli you cannot and if you look up
and smile we are
wired to look up to heaven let's say and
be hopeful and we are wired that when we
smile the neurochemistry of happiness is
firing through our bloodstream and so if
you just do inner size number one and
two now you get awareness and you calm
down the circuits and then if you learn
inner size number three
it's called actors it's called um
um
actress uh no hold on i'm losing inner
size number three uh it is called uh
it'll come back to me in just a moment
but the the um
the third inner size is around it's an
actor's studio exercise basically it's
an inner size so any actor in the world
can switch from being happy or sad or
mad or disappointed or or any modality
of physiology that you want them to take
on
they can command it on command right
right and so if somebody's unhappy could
you teach yourself to be happy in less
than three seconds and the answer is yes
if you chose to so control of emotions
control of emotions and so when we focus
on
the the core emotions people have of
happiness sadness shame uh disgust
contempt love
we can learn how to switch between those
on any given moment
but most people what happens they get
caught up in this emotion energy in
motion that's negative or disempowering
and then they think about how they feel
and they feel what they're thinking
about and they keep perpetuating the
same pattern
and that's not where it ends and this is
where the problem lays is if you do that
on a regular basis your brain says since
you're repeating this uh let me just
make this
um you know a habit and i'll just create
that on command-free so you're in that
state more frequently and then they
don't know how to interrupt that pattern
and create a new empowered state i'm
always looking for
consistency
around all of my content does that make
sense to you if it makes sense just tell
me john that makes total sense so so far
we have you know define what your brand
stands for if your brand could speak
what would your brand say about you
right if your brand could speak
what would your brand say about you is
your brand fast is your brand slow is
your brand laxie
where it's just a just free flow by
hanian you know or is it more you know
um more sharp edges
so you have to think about this and that
if you're looking to build a personal
brand if you're looking to build a
personal brand then you need to think
about what does my brand stand for what
do i want people to think and feel
about my personal brand so that i own
some space okay in their brain so let me
ask you a question let's have a little
bit of fun
when i share with you um the personal
brand
oprah what do you
feel about the brand what do you feel
about the brand
is it a brand that you trust
is it a brand that is fast or calm
like what do you feel when you hear the
word oprah or what do you feel when you
hear the you know the um the brand elon
musk
right what do you what does it make you
feel because every brand develops
consistency and the consistency creates
a feeling and people gravitate towards
how a brand makes them feel right
does a brand make you feel appreciated
that you can trust it uh that it's safe
or that it's risky like elon musk is a
risk taker right he's a different brand
than oprah and yet he's got a huge
following he will make a comment and you
know and cryptocurrency goes through the
roof
right so what does your brand stand for
let's say
you have a goal
okay any goal um a financial goal a
travel goal a net worth goal uh have my
own blog post or blog and and have a
tribe follow me goal and that's your
vision and your goal that you've
consciously chosen
but then beneath the surface
you feel
am i really worthy of that
am i really good enough
am i really smart enough do i really
deserve that
anytime you have a vision or a goal
that is positive and and fun and amazing
but there is a subconscious
negative or disempowering pattern like
self-esteem self-worth or self-image
the negative disempowering pattern wins
98 of the time wow
so if you think about the positive
vision and goal as being the you know
the positive if we have the positive and
the negative we have chaos in the brain
and what we really want to create more
of is coherence so what's coherence well
imagine you um if everybody just
think about going to your favorite band
your favorite bands coming to town all
right and you are so excited because you
just love to hear them but
um their drummer or their lead vocalist
or their guitarist got sick a few days
ago and they had to get somebody else to
play you know tonight when you're going
to see them play
and they haven't had a chance to
practice together and this new band
member is just not in tune with
everybody else there's going to be chaos
it's like oh he's off the vocals are off
or where the piano's off or the guitar
is off it just doesn't sound right or
feel right and then the whole thing's
awesome it's off so it's like the
experience is like there's no harmony
here
right so when people's vision or goals
are out of harmony with their
subconscious self-esteem or fears or
limiting beliefs there's chaos and there
isn't there's too much friction and the
action in the absence of um a friction
you have smooth but when there's
friction there it's just not smooth it's
not in harmony when i analyze businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing
and so when we start to focus on
getting the inner game right plus what
you need to do
and then you do it
the results are pretty easy
so here's what i want you to ask
yourself
are there people out there
all right that could buy your product or
service but you don't know how to reach
them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling
offering to the marketplace is it
possible that you just don't know how to
reach them
so that means that it's a skill set
issue right
now
in 2021
we know how to do those things there
like i said earlier where i started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day
online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right um when we
didn't have the internet we had to
advertise you know the newspapers
postcards
magazines radio television or set up a
store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay
is online offering information content
to develop a relationship and rapport
with prospects and they're taking them
through a process yellow pages that's
right thank you
muse debbie debbie muse
right so yellow pages
so
here's the thing one of the formulas
that you must figure out is where i
started before
traffic times conversion equals revenue
the added version to that is traffic
times conversion plus
repeat business and referrals equals
exponential revenue
traffic times conversion equals revenue
now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today i'm gonna give you
a couple things number one is i need to
adapt i need to adapt to the market and
use all the tools available to me but
not use every one of them
i want you to ask yourself the question
i posed earlier is what has to happen in
order for me to just double or triple
the leads that i get
leads
the the prospects coming to see you
online or offline if you just focused on
that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and i'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer virginia yeah this
is
this is my new york times best-selling
book the answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a new york times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh i put that back
over there
on my on my thing um but i didn't come
here to to sell you on my on my book i
want to give you information if anybody
wants to get the book on amazon for 15
or less
it'll blow your mind and the lux coast
you're reading it now awesome so
when we understand there's already a
process in
place and we discover
how do we take our product or service
and create the marketing how many of you
are you good in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning i'm
not talking about branding
i'm talking about getting your product
or service with the right message
in front of the ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay i
want you let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner
there's a couple of different hats that
you have to make sure are being taken
care of right in business if you're a
business owner with a product or service
you have to have somebody who's doing
the marketing right which is developing
your brand creating your messaging for
how you're going to promote your product
or service to people who don't know you
you have to learn how to sell and
selling is doing something for somebody
not to somebody
you need to learn how to manage you need
to learn how to either develop products
you need to learn some of the technology
needs that you have there's a lot of
different hats
that you have to wear
or you have to make sure that somebody
in your company
is wearing that hat right
and so
imagine if you're
needs surgery but you're not a good
surgeon what would you do
you'd have to find how do i get somebody
who could do the surgery so for those of
you who are not good at marketing or
sales which is the oxygen required for
any business regardless of how good your
product or service are
the question you want to be asking
yourself is this who can i hire to help
me
or who can i barter with to help me who
can i partner with to help me
do my marketing and sales if you're not
good at that so hire
partner barter
or
defer payment to get it done because
without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or
you don't have you're not good at you
don't want it but you still need to
figure out as a business owner how am i
going to get it done your job as a
business owner is not to do everything
but to make sure that everything that is
oxygen and is required gets done if you
were out of shape physical shape okay
how would you get back in shape like
what would you do
think let's be realistic logical if
you're out of shape you've been out of
shape you're overweight uh you're not as
healthy as you can be
right what would you do if you made a
commitment to be in shape okay right if
you were committed to being in shape
let's talk about physically right now
what would you do to break the pattern
the software
so
somebody says you could diet you can
exercise
you can sleep
well right get six to eight hours of
sleep so you reduce your cortisol levels
and reduce your leptin levels so diet go
on go to the gym visualize motivate
willie says start gradually um right you
can
you can create a vision board and see
yourself right in shape
right you can start with small steps you
can get an accountability partner you
can join a gym you can hire a coach
you can ask a
family member or friend if she or he
would like to you know start small so
you can develop the habits magic 321
right so what our habits habits are
automatic combinations of thoughts
emotions
feelings sensations and behaviors that
are all automatic to do without thought
but to get to a habit
right to get to a habit we have to start
all right with how we think right
we have to continue with how do we feel
motivated or unmotivated well how do we
get motivated how do we stay motivated
then we need to know what are the
behaviors that we want to take so we
want to work
on an inner
game and an outer game so all of my
students for example all my private
clients whether i'm working with a ceo
or an athlete or a homemaker doesn't
matter i ask them to commit to
days
okay to develop a new
pattern
that they can reinforce
so do you think it's reasonable let me
ask you a question
do you think it's reasonable
to say to yourself
that i'm going to commit to 100 days to
give myself the best chances of a solid
foundation that i could build upon so
instead of thinking that i'm going to
change
a result or change a habit that i've had
for 10 20 30 years in a weekend or in a
week or two or three that's just
unrealistic do you think that if we just
change the expectation
and we said okay
i'm going to do it fast
but i'm not going to do it so fast that
i don't sustain
sustain the thinking the emotions and
the behaviors so here's what i want to
ask you right if you're committed to an
outcome that you don't just want to
achieve and then stop
right
then why not commit to a process that
you can continue
and people will do things
for either a reason
a season or a lifetime a reason a season
or a lifetime here's what we know okay
let's say
you've been earning a certain amount of
income for the last you know 10 years
all right within range and you want to
maybe double or triple your income
isn't it worth it
to be disciplined
to
sustainable change versus you know rapid
change that goes away
if we are creatures of habit
then why not get really good at develop
empowering constructive
positive habits
why not get good at upgrading our own
mental and emotional behavioral software
so that once we do it we can just
sustain it because we set a new
expectation for ourselves there's too
many people
okay
out there teaching you know fast food
thinking you know lose all the weight in
seven days well you're gonna gain it all
back because most of the weight you lose
is water
right uh let's see how much money i can
make this weekend well that's great but
you're not going to sustain it because
the habit is not there
this is why
people who win the lottery lose it
within three years and people who lose
money that they've made it
gain it back within three years because
they have the neural pattern
of the behavior you have to get
the
word out that you're out there and you
can do it right now inexpensively online
you can do it through networking you can
do it through being in groups you can do
it a variety of different ways and every
one of your strategies of what you do
has to match your ability to execute and
do it so don't pick a strategy like
doing videos if you hate being on camera
don't uh say i'm going to write articles
if you're not going to write yourself or
hire a company to write for you so pick
the strategies that you're actually
going to do to completion and here's
what i recommend
if you want to start solving the rubik's
cube start with the two by two then
three by three and four by four why
because in learning the two by two you
learn the fundamentals for the three by
three and that translates to you
doing things in business that's actually
easy for you to do or easy for you to
learn
first
as the ceo of your company you need to
be focusing every day
on marketing and generating leads
and every day on converting those leads
into paying customers and then every day
the people that don't buy you need to
nurture them and develop a relationship
with them and when you focus on lead
generation lead conversion and lead
nurturing
now you have a daily process of what
every business owner that makes it to a
hundred thousand two fifty five 500 a
million
consistently knows they had to figure
out and when you want to get to the next
level the next level the next level it's
a function of more leads that are
qualified that you convert that you
nurture and then you create some
processes and systems that'll help you
grow and scale
thinking the right way is just as
important as doing the right things so
don't get caught up just doing a whole
bunch of stuff
do the right things in the right order
at the right time and that'll be like
opening up a safe with the right
combination here's what i learned many
many years ago and i'm going to leave
you with this
one of my mentors who is a billionaire
said john i don't want you to get
stronger at your weaknesses
i want you to get stronger at your
strengths
i want you to manage your weaknesses
hmm manage my weaknesses i said to him
how do i manage my weaknesses he says
you practice radical honesty about what
you're strong in
create a plan to get better and you are
radically honest what you're not good at
and you find people to help you
who are good at that now here is what
i'm going to leave you with
he said to me
hire people
who play
at things you have to work at
hire people who play
at things
you have to work at and i can fill in
the blank like i did before say you can
hire bar to defer payment or partner
with people who play at the things that
you have to work at
all right so
if you're not good at certain parts of
business that's okay you need to admit
you're not good at it but your job as
the ceo of your business is to figure
out how am i going to get that done
by asking better questions you get
better answers but by saying i'm not
good at that i don't know how to do that
i don't like that you're reinforcing
your patterns in your brain
you're reinforcing patterns in your
brain that are going to make you worse
at it
so instead of putting yourself down lift
yourself up instead of coming up with
stories and reasons and excuses why you
can't focus your brain on how you will
because you must you gotta clear through
the noise of negativity out there stay
positive because
people are buying people are buying
people are buying right now
right now
and that means that there is more
business available to you but you have
to manage your mindset upgrade your
skill set and then make sure that you're
taking the right actions in the right
order at the right time if your
self-image
is not in coherence
with the goal that you want to achieve
you'll sabotage your success we
discovered that self-esteem if there's a
disconnect between our vision and goals
and self-esteem self-esteem will drag us
down procrastinate sabotage rationalize
those are the causes or the self-esteem
is one of the causes that holds us back
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there